[Funny Music]
Woman: When you launch a new app on Google Play
Are likely to have been achieved from all aspects of the application,
Such as quality test and make sure to fix errors.
The application should also be realized
Taking into account the policy we adopt.
Here are ten ways to ensure compliance
Google Play policy.
Application Developer Policy Center ...
Is your reference to all Google Play policy matters.
We have organized policies by subject
We put them into boxes.
You can choose a policy to read more about
See examples of common violations.
You can take some time to describe your app
To avoid violating the metadata policy.
You should read the short and full description
Remove any redundant keyword lists,
Or inappropriate information or inappropriate certificates from users.
Application description should be appropriate for all ages
And to comply with any translation to describe the application
Metadata policy.
If you want to comply fully
With regard to intellectual property policy,
It's a good idea to create your own photos and videos
To promote your app.
You should make sure you have the right to use
App icon, icon, and any other assets
Upload them to your store listing.
If you have permission to use assets
Third party, you can inform the application review team
Via filling out this form.
Like application description,
All images and videos in your app should be appropriate
With all ages.
After completing the content evaluation questionnaire,
You are almost ready to send the application.
Accurate responses should also be provided
In order to get an accurate assessment
Applications that are not properly evaluated,
Or not rated at all, may be deleted from the Play Store.
Does your app collect user data?
User data includes information provided by users,
Or information about users, or those associated with their interactions
With the application or device.
If you are collecting user data,
You must include a privacy policy
In your store listing and in your app.
Privacy policy should be set for users
The data collected by your application and the purpose of its collection.
Read the personal and sensitive data section
Under the User Data Policy
To see which data types to watch out for.
When you submit the application for review,
The Google Play team also reviews content
Ads and their interactions within your app.
Make sure your ad content is not pornographic or violent,
Or any material that may violate our content policy.
The ad must interact directly.
We do not allow ads that are interceptive or deceptive,
Including ads that appear to be notifications from the system,
Or those that can not be removed,
Or that appear after the user closes the application.
A policy ad issue may result in an app disapproval
Or suspension.
Check your ad provider for filter options.
See your app and your store listing page
To make sure they are free from any restricted content, such as pornographic content
Violence or drugs.
If you're concerned about any content in your app,
You can read the restricted content policy
For more details and examples.
Applications that include or display user-generated content,
Additional measures should be taken to ensure
The app experience is consistent with the policy.
If this applies to your app,
Review our User-Created Content Policy for more information.
You are almost ready to send the app, but only one thing left.
Take a minute to update your email address
And the Account Details page in the Developer Console.
If a policy issue occurs,
We can contact you to let you know what steps you need to resolve.
Congratulations.
It's time to press the bright blue publishing button.
While you've verified that your app complies with our policies,
But your application may be rejected
Or suspension after review.
If the application refuses or refuses to update it,
You can always handle violations.
Just follow the steps in the notification
In the Google Play email you received
Then fix the problem and submit your application again.
If you do not agree to a policy violation,
Or if you want to help resolve your policy issue,
You can contact the policy support team.
Simply use the contact details in the email notice
Or click the question mark at the bottom of each page
In the Policy Center website.
For a quick response,
Be sure to include your package name.
For more information about Google Play policy,
Visit the Application Developer Policy Center.
Learn more about how to launch your app
Or the development of your business,
You can see other videos in this series
And download the Playbook for Developers app
Via Google Play.